So, if you're T3 and T4 are normal, and you still have fatigue, you start looking first.
You start looking for other reasons for fatigue because your main symptom of low thyroid
is going to be fatigue, weight gain, hair loss, those are going to be your main symptoms.
You look for those main symptoms of low thyroid and you adjust your thyroid medication or supplementation.
My thyroid labs are normal then, so I guess then I would just leave your thyroid alone right now.
Okay, and then I heard you say something about not doing anything to stimulate the immune system.
I recently started doing just for maintenance purposes and for preventative was subcutaneous mistletoe injections, so now I wonder if I should be doing that.
Well, so again, in my book, treated cancer, you know, way over trumps your thyroid.
Yeah, by going to mistletoe or using mushrooms or using any immune stimulants that anybody would be using for cancer, it's going to increase your number of thyroid antibody production, which that is going to possibly increase the damage to the thyroid.
You don't have to worry about it. You have enough thyroid cells, so you're not going to ever destroy your thyroid with Hashimoto's.
Nor are you ever going to not be able to replenish those cells, so that's not even something you need to even be concerned with.
You just got to keep your thyroid in balance and deal with your other things, you need, you know, first, you need number one, if you're going to prioritize what you're treating, you treat your cancer first.
You nobody's going to die of Hashimoto's disease, so you treat your cancer first, and then looking at your labs.
The next thing you go to is you want to treat the mold and thyroid is weighed out of the list.
I would treat the thyroid along with it if I was having symptoms and my thyroid labs, my T3 and T4 were way out of balance.
Well, there's another wrong with treating that too, so you feel better, but I won't even be looking at the thyroid antibody test right now.
Okay, that's not even concerned, and you really shouldn't be because you're going to probably spike your thyroid antibodies high.
If you're going to do things to kill cancer cells and you're going to do things to kill mold, because in doing that, you're basically having to stimulate an immune response to do that.
So when you stimulate an immune response, you're going to increase antibodies to things that you already have antibodies to, which is your thyroid plant.
Okay, I don't even worry about that.
Okay, so what do I do about this mold right now? I have, I'm doing, I'll tell you what I am doing, and then just get your feedback.
I'm doing charcoal binders, I do two of those a day, and then I do a sauna, and then part of doing the sauna, I do not take a niacin, and then I take in a sea after the sauna.
Okay, because my body is not producing glutathione, so.
But you can take glutathione, you know, yeah, but I thought we didn't want to supplement that put it on negative feedback loop or something.
Well, not really, so glutathione works, glutathione replenishes itself, so that's one nice thing about glutathione becomes oxidized, reduced and reoxidized again, reduced, and so it just goes in this loop to replenish itself.
However, people with autoimmune disease, people with Lyme disease, people with mold, it can be extremely helpful just to add glutathione to your production.
By taking in a sea, that's a precursor to glutathione, you're helping your body make more glutathione, but, you know, when you're dealing with a lot of things, it can be really beneficial just to add glutathione.
The problem has always been throughout the years, is just by taking glutathione, it's, you're going to absorb like 2% of what you'll take.
Well, then they came out with acetyl-alglutathione and the percentage of absorption went up to about 15 to 20%, so that was huge benefit, right?
Now they have glutathione in multiple forms that's lipozomal.
So your percentage of absorption goes up even higher, maybe 2 to 3 times that, maybe 40 to 60% of absorption.
So taking lipozomal glutathione could be very beneficial in your case as well, but I agree with everything else you're doing, too.
Okay, so anything else that I should be doing on top of that outside of the right, I mean, is there, I want to talk about the right, but I mean, be outside of the right, is there anything else that I could be doing to get rid of the mold, and what, what are your thoughts on this mold test, like, what are those two molds and.
These are common molds that people have that are that they're exposed to household molds.
But we see quite a bit, so this is a good lab, great planes lab is a great lab, this is a good, these are good tests.
So having these two molds, it's like, okay, I have them, I've been exposed to them throughout my life, probably, now how do I get rid of them?
You're doing the right things, all I would say is maybe add the lipozomal glutathione, actually it says it right here, lipozomal glutathione, I didn't read that.
And then this rose maritic acid, the, what we use for that is the, or solid acid.
What is it, your cellic, or solid acid, yeah.
Okay, I take that from you, yeah.
Okay, good, that's that, that's what that is.
And then it could take a long time to get rid of mold of your body, so you just have to be patient, I mean, years.
And the reason why I say you should concentrate on it, meeting that you should just do some things actively to deal with it because this can be a precursor to cancer mold, not thyroid.
Right.
So, like it scares me if it's there, how do I know that I can keep this?
Quite honestly, if you did 100 people off the street, you did it 10 to 15% would probably have positive.
Okay.
So I wouldn't be scared about it. It's like, oh, okay, I have it. I've been exposed to mold at some point in my life.
The other thing you should look at when you're exposed to this is like, do I have correct exposure?
Yeah, we had our house tested, we had the air tested and it was negative.
And then I just ordered one of those claws so that I could test surfaces.
Yeah, it would, it would be in the air and that's the biggest, because you breed it and it is going to be the biggest thing.
So, you know, with numbers 10 times higher than this, that because they had molded their walls and they didn't know it.
And one doctor actually, who they almost, he and his wife were so sick, they were near death.
And they had a brand new house and there was no sight of mold anywhere until they tore the sheet rock off the bathroom wall that was their master bathroom.
Right.
All black cost them $150,000 to fix the tear it all out and a tear off half their house.
But they were near death.
So how, how much, how often do you think I should be doing? I'm trying to prioritize all of my treatments.
Like, I'm starting to back to work in a couple of weeks and I'm trying to like, how many times a week do you think I need to be doing this?
Oh, this coffee animus help with mold.
That really, I mean, no, I mean, yes, because it helps stimulate parasympathetics and it helps stimulate detoxification.
What we can do is we can tweak your overnight program to put mold in it so that you don't have to write run separate programs.
Okay, so because that's what I was wondering like, okay, so right now my overnight program is what just breast cancer.
And the other things that came up on your hands.
Oh, okay.
I mean, would that be something that would benefit me to come in and have you rescan me so or no.
No, no, we could just add mold to the picture.
Okay.
So we'll just shorten the dwell on everything else you still have all the other programming.
But then we'll just do the first thing that you get as you go to bed at night. We'll just have like an hour of mold or something.
And then does anything.
Okay, so, and then what are your thoughts on the mistletoe injection subcue?
So mistletoe injections are great to stimulate an immune response. That's the whole purpose of them.
Is it something you need to do right now if you're looking to prioritize everything.
You know, give it given that you have a path scan that had zero evidence of anything going on.
No, I wouldn't say it's something you need to do right now.
But like what I don't want it to metastasize.
Like I like to.
I'm really working hard on.
And I know you've known this about me, but it's pure.
And I feel like I do really good for a few weeks and then I have a bad week and then I do really good.
And I feel like I made the worst decision ever. I'm like, I can't, I like sometimes I'm like, oh my gosh, I can't believe I chose not to do chemo and radiation.
Can I really survive without doing that?
Is that a question?
Yeah.
Well, yeah, there's tons of evidence of people really surviving without doing that.
And you actually made the better decision because let's say your cancer comes back.
The worst case scenario, your cancer comes back.
Now you have the ability to use chemo and radio.
Right, but everyone I hear says that once in metastasize, it's too late.
No, the problem.
What what makes it too late is that the people did chemo and radiation.
And then they then they were told, oh, you're doing great.
You got to clean bill of health. And two years later, and metastasizes.
And now the chemo doesn't work for them.
Okay.
That's why you're better off trying to get it into remission without chemo so that you can keep those big guns in your back pocket.
So you were in a way better position than somebody that did chemo.
To get to the point where you are right now.
And so my thing is that I just want to make sure so that I can move.
Oh, sorry, move on with life and enjoy life is that I'm doing.
That I'm doing everything so it doesn't come back.
I get it.
So you can keep you can keep doing the missile.
So it's just that you made a combat that you're trying to prioritize.
Yeah.
I just didn't know like if you saw benefit in it for.
So if you feel led to do the continue to do the missile to them by all means keep doing that.
That doesn't take a lot of time.
No, it's the shot three times a week.
Right.
And I don't know.
Do you know who Mark he and Coxes and Georgia.
I don't.
Okay.
That's who I'm going through.
But.
Okay.
He worked.
I mean, he worked under.
I don't know.
Make sure that it doesn't come back.
Yeah.
So if you feel led to do the continue to do the missile to them by all means keep doing that.
That doesn't take a lot of time.
No, it's the shot three times a week.
Right.
And I don't know.
Do you know who Mark he and Coxes and Georgia.
I don't.
Okay.
He works with her.
And that's how I've gotten his name.
Okay.
Um,
So what I'm doing is right now is my diet.
I'm doing the keto therapeutic.
I switched over because I what I needed more meat in my diet because I was just getting so skinny.
And I just and I just didn't feel right.
So, but I.
It's still like nine to ten veggies a day.
But then I add.
I can do eggs, chicken and salmon.
Okay.
And I look back at your protocol and it was.
It fell and I met that too.
So.
All right.
I mean, and so that's I'm doing that.
Exercise.
I try to work exercise at least 35 minutes a day.
But right now I haven't been.
I haven't been feeling good.
And then.
The mistletoe.
You know, all my all my supplements.
And that's nothing too.
I'm wondering if I need to come back in because some of my supplements have changed.
If I need to come back in and do muscle testing with them.
We can.
We'd love to see you again.
Okay.
You're not that far away.
No.
Any what other recommendation.
Oh, and then let's talk about the Dutch test or.
I don't know.
Okay.
I just passed what I'm doing for my Dutch.
I mean, for my hormones is.
I'm doing flaxseed two tablespoons a day.
Dim.
And then.
High dose melatonin.
I'm doing 180 grams at night or 180, whatever it is at 90.
Miller grams.
Yeah.
Okay.
So.
High dose melatonin.
Yeah, your hormones are great.
The only thing that's not great with your hormones.
Is your cortisol is high.
That's the only thing.
So cortisol is a function of your adrenal glands.
And that could possibly be.
I'll have to look up some information whether melatonin affects that or not.
Yeah.
Just knowing you.
I would say you're prone to high cortisol because you're.
You're very.
High anxiety.
Yeah.
So.
But the good news for you is.
Knowing your personality.
Knowing that you're fairly high anxiety.
For you to have high cortisol.
Is.
Okay.
So a lot of people that are hot that are anxious people more anxious than others.
Can you see my cursor here?
Yeah.
Okay.
So this red is yours.
Right.
You're supposed to have a spike in the morning of cortisol, but it's supposed to be down here.
Okay.
You're.
So that's all.
There are people that,
that tend to be high anxiety.
And have unhealthy adrenal glands.
This red light, is like.
Distra-, at this light is not this is straight line at the bottom down here.
There are drills are just shot.
Okay.
You see that a lot.
Yours are high and that tells, that tells you okay, either this person is.
an individual meeting that they're not an anxious person but they're under current stress.
Or somebody like you that is a little bit more high anxiety and you have extremely healthy
adrenal glands. So if there's good news to be said about this is you have extremely healthy adrenal
glands. Okay. If there's bad news to be said, you have high cortisol. Well, what's the danger of
high cortisol? Well, the biggest danger of high cortisol is that you sleep issues. The person
just, I don't sleep at night. Right. I don't know. Okay. So then then I wouldn't be really concerned.
Your curve itself is beautiful. See, it's just, it's great. It's just high. It's just a little high
down here. Your afternoon is like perfect. So it's just, you're a little stressed in the morning
and again, got to remember this test. The cortisol changes every day. So you could have
enscued a little bit by maybe you were a little more stressed the day you took this test.
And this one's three months old. And so I am, I had a hysterectomy. And so I currently am doing
testing my from my ovulations so I can do this again. Okay. All right. The seed you like did
Jade had me start taking the melatonin that and the flax seeds. And I want to see that do anything.
What is she, what is she looking for? I don't know what?
Well, she's flax seeds can be precursor for estrogens. And the one you're concerned with
is, is this one right here. This is the bad estrogen that you don't want high.
So this is what the O-A-E. This is the four hydroxy estradialde. So the four O-H-E-1.
Is mine high? No, it's still with the normal limits. You don't want, if a person's got cancer,
you don't want this green arrow to be over here. All right. So I mean, you're fine. And now with your
hysterectomy, that's going to change completely. It's probably going to be done here.
Well, my hysterectomy was done several years before I had breast cancer.
Oh, that's right. All right. So. So then if my estrogens look good, then how did I get breast cancer?
That's estrogen positive. The estrogen positive has to do with the receptors on the cancer cells.
That means all that means all estrogen positive breast cancer means is these guys here would drive it.
These guys would be drivers of the cancer. It doesn't mean it's the cause.
Oh, okay. So if my cancer's gone out of my body and currently, this really means that not much at all.
No. So then why do they put you on tomoxifen? Like, that my oncology-
tomoxifen just shuts on this whole pathway down. So these would be way down.
Somebody to go on to moxifen? No. If we can't get their cancer under control any other way,
it's another choice. Okay. So you are going to do this test again in the next couple of months.
Yeah. So soon as I ovulate, I won't do it. Make sure you tell me it's true you said it to me.
Yeah, I will. Because right after this came back is when she started me on the flax seed and the
what was the other thing? Sorry. Oh, the high dose melatonin. Is there anything else according to
this test that you think that I should be taking? If you didn't have cancer, we would give you some
methyl groups because of this right here. So you're getting less methylation of this. That's
why this is very low. But we see this commonly with cancer because we don't want cancer patients
to be out a lot of methyl groups. If you came in with any, we took you off of them. Right. Yeah.
We don't worry about that. Otherwise, this just explains that whole cortisol thing.
So you think that my Dutch test looks good? Yeah, I think your Dutch test looks good. It's just that
cortisol piece. And then this is all one test. Okay. And then the right you said you're going to add
the molds to it. What other recommendations do you have for me? That would be number one.
And then with the mold, maybe the liposomal glutathione. Okay. Oh, and then how often do you
recommend to do the sauna that it's going to impact it? You know what I'm saying? How many times a week
to get the benefit? Well, you could do sauna. I mean, if you want the best benefit from sauna,
doing it at least twice a week would be good. Okay. And if you really enjoy it, you could do it
more. Right. I just want to make sure I'm doing at least the minimum to get the benefit from it.
And then it needed to be more because what I was doing was doing like doing the sauna and then
showering right away to get all those toxins off of me. Yeah. And then I would do the coffee
animal. Yeah. And that's good. So go back to the coffee animal again once. What would be the benefits
of Amy Ellis doing the coffee animal? Well, specifically for you, the biggest benefit of the coffee
animal is to stimulate your parasympathetics, which calms me down. Yes.
Parasympathetics. Okay. And what's the minimum? Did you say that there are some videos on your
website for these coffee animals? Yeah, there's videos on the blog just search coffee animals and
the shelves. Look at Michelle's what hers are the best. And some people say, gosh, I can only hold it
for two minutes. That's okay. That's okay. Oh, that's good to know. Because there are some days
I can hold it for 12. And then there's other days I can only hold it for five. I can, personally,
I could never hold it more than about three minutes. Are you still getting the benefits?
Still getting the benefit. And then what about glutathione production? Does it help with that?
No, not really. So, but the coffee animal is going to help with stimulate detox pathways
in your liver. So going back to what I think you should do based on these tests,
continue doing everything you're doing currently. Maybe getting back to doing several coffee animals
a week. When you say several, what's that? Well, maybe just do it every time you do the sauna.
Consider adding the liposomal glutathione. Okay. And then it will change your programs on the
rife so that you that won't take any more of your time of your day doing those. And then could I get
what about the the foot bath? Because I'm going to top be honest with you. I that's the one thing I
gave up when my I got my CTCs back to zero. And I don't so I need to get I think I need to get back
doing those. So, if you get back to doing the foot bath said I want to just wait until we said
you the flash drive for the program for the new update program because then we'll put some
of the most appropriate foot baths to do in the in your folder. Okay. And then how many of those
foot baths should I be doing a week? You could do maybe one or two a week. Okay. Okay. Anything else
that I need to do to make sure that this doesn't come back? Stay in contact with me. Okay. I um
I'll schedule an appointment. I need a scheduled appointment to come up and
bring up my supplements and have you read the test them all because Jade switched on my switched
a bunch of my supplements up because of my Hashimoto's. So I just really want to talk to you about
that more too. Okay. Because she didn't want me on some stuff because she thought it would stimulate
that. Yeah. And I just would not again reiterate your Hashimoto's. Hashimoto's is never going to kill
anybody. Hashimoto's is not going to destroy your life. Hashimoto's is going to make you symptomatic
by giving you a low thyroid. And if you have that under control and you control that piece which is
relatively, I'm not saying it's easy or or or it's it's not taking time to figure out because some
people's thyroid just bounces all over the place and you're they're always playing with their dose.
But compared to dealing with cancer or dealing with mold or lime, it's up. I mean
it's nothing. And I do have a lot of brain fog. Could that be from the mold?
That's probably from the mold not the Hashimoto's. Okay. Now it can it could be from the Hashimoto's
if the person had T3 and T4 at like one. Yeah. No, my T3 and T4 are good. Okay. Well,
you have normal blood you have normal blood thyroid. So that you're not going to have any symptoms
when you have normal blood thyroid hormones. The the the antibodies are not going to cause symptoms.
They're not going to cause problems. They're just going to cause destruction of the thyroid. But as long
as the thyroid could continue to repair and make up for it, could still kick out hormones and we don't
worry. Okay. Okay. How are you feeling? Feeling good? Are you doing good? Yeah. Doing all right.
Okay. Well, I'd pray for you. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you. I pray for you too. Thank you. Okay.
As far as the liposomal glutathione, if if if your practitioner down there carries apex
brand apex energetics, that's probably the best source for it. I know quick silver has one two that's
really good, but there's is is more expensive apex energetics. We have it in our store, but you have
to call it in because apex does not let you sell online. Okay. So our apex products people have to call
in. It's only it's a liquid. It comes in a big bottle. So if you get it from us, you have to
call in the order. If you get it from your practitioner, if they can get apex energetics. Okay. And then
just to boost my confidence and just I just I just that's what I pray for the most is just I want
confidence that what I did was right. So I mean, do you have patients or do you know patients that
have had breast cancer that are fine? But didn't do chemo and radiation? Yeah, we have a lot.
We have breast cancer patients. We just got an email from one today who when she came to us,
her breast was she had this giant mass in her breast, right? And she was just adamant. She's not
doing chemo. She's not going to do that. She's not going to do their stuff, right? And her tumor was
coming out of her breast. And so she's got this open wound on her breast. And we learned from
our patients. So we were learning and prayed about what to do next. This person is not in good
condition, right? Well, now we have a protocol for that for an open wound of the breast because we
started with her with black SAV. And she lit she sent us an email today that she feels completely
back to normal. She feels like because multiple times over the last three months, starting
with she did started the black SAV about three, four months ago. These tumors were coming out.
And we kept telling her to reapply it. The tumors keep coming out. So these little gobs keep coming
out. So she just emailed us today saying she actually feels for the first time since she was diagnosed,
she feels normal again. And that her breast is all deformed, but it already was deformed.
But she feels like the cancer is dead. Wow. And that's what I just keep praying for and asking
is this and I want God just to give me peace that I know that what I did was right. And you know,
and I want to know that I'm going to live to be cancer-free. And I just worry about my children,
you know, and just... Well, there's nothing wrong with worrying about your children and
wanting things in our life. But I would just caution you to just pray for God's will in your life
above all things. That you can fulfill His will and bring Him glory above everything because you
could live to be 110 years old and still die and go to hell. No, yeah, I know. I just want to know
that there is... I mean, even though... I mean, it was in my lymph nodes, you know, and it's hard
where I live. And I'm sure Minnesota is like this too. But it's like people look at me like I'm crazy
that I didn't do. And people still doubt my decision. So when other people doubt my decision,
then it scares me, you know. Yeah, well, you don't need other people's approval. And maybe that's
part of the lesson that God has in this for you is that you're not... You just don't care about other
people's approval. And I get it. I'm at a different level than most people because I became a car
proctor when car proctors were not cool. So I had to deal with people's doubt and disapproval of me
for the last 35 years. And now I just don't give a crap anymore. So it's easy for me to
buck the system because, you know, I still care what people think about me. For going to say,
I haven't worn a mask since this whole COVID thing came out. I just... I still care what people think.
And I get bad looks and comments all the time. I just... I'm not going to be made to people, but I don't
care what you think anymore. So maybe that's part of one of the hundred lessons for you to learn is to
stand strong on the faith that God gives you and what he's teaching you and and abide by his
calling no matter what. Otherwise we just become conformers to other people and then we can't be
useful to the kingdom at all. Right. I just don't want to, you know, two, three years down the road
and regret, you know, oh, I made the worst mistake. I wouldn't be here. I just... I know that I
can't guarantee my life no matter what, but I want to do everything I can to... Well, I can tell
I can't guarantee your life either. And you could have the cancer come back in two or three years and be dead.
But the truth is, is you are in a hundred times better shape.
Have keeping chemo and radiation in your back pocket. Then if you would have used it to get to
this position, because we see that more than as far as breast cancer patients that we have,
the majority of them have done chemo and radiation. And now they're at that a year later it came
back with the vengeance. Or they're in the middle of they're just finishing up their chemo. And now they
found out that metastasized and the doctor said, okay, which they switched chemo three times already
and nothing's working. And then they call us. It's like, gosh, you know, I would never say this to them.
But the truth is, if you just would have started on this path first. Right. And I still sleep with my
wife religiously every night. And better. Okay. Nothing changes with that. Still sleep with it every
night. Yeah. Okay. All right. We're going to get to go go on on this program. And then we'll get
this out to you. Well, probably won't be till tomorrow. Thank you so much. I appreciate talking to
you. It's always good to hear your voice. All right. Give your house. But a big kiss for me. I will.
God bless you. Bye-bye.